all right and if you're ready to travel
like i am and i'm sure everyone in this
station right now
you're not alone three out of four
americans recently surveyed say
a recently survey say that a dream
vacation is in the works and they are
ready to spend
while they're on vacation here's some
advice from hilton hotels the sponsors
of this segment
to help you save money and create
memories at the same time
by some definitions travel can make you
rich
the real definition of wealth is the
condition of well-being
and so really we believe in creating
relationships that matter
that that's a part of that and i wasn't
surprised when the survey revealed that
almost 40
of americans are really thinking you
know i really want travel to be at the
top of the list because i miss seeing
friends and family
to create the memories but stick to a
budget find a hotel with perks that save
money
and consider a suite or get a room with
a full kitchen
maybe like home to suites by hilton end
oh my gosh they're so spacious for the
big groups but you can also
cook in the room have drinks in the room
and you'll save a ton of money rather
than eating out the entire trip
other tips for saving on the go sign up
for hotel loyalty programs and use a
credit card with travel points
before you pack your bags download
travel apps related to your destination
or to your hotels such as the hilton
honors app and start your research at
hilton.com
i am ready to go thank you again to
hilton hotels for sponsoring this
segment we'll be right back